It's so fun for me to be here.
Uh,
for a number of reasons.
One is I live two blocks away,
so this is the easiest speaking thing possible.
The others I was telling Jacqueline,
it's like coming back to high school.
I left Google about eight years ago and it's like all these memories come
flooding back.
This building actually wasn't a Google building when I left,
but um,
it's,
you know,
it's all consistent branding and all that,
so it brings back lots of good memories.
Um,
so when I left Google eight years ago,
I decided to spend the second half of my career working towards social goods,
specifically focused on global poverty.
And you know,
I had spent my whole career in the tech world.
I studied as a software engineer or as an engineering director.
Um,
I knew how to build software,
but,
um,
I knew nothing about global poverty,
so I knew I had a lot to learn.
Um,
and I wasn't really sure how I could contribute a,
at first everyone was trying to come to me to help them build an app for this or
that or build a website.
And it wasn't clear to me that that was really going to be a highest and best
use.
Um,
so I set out to learn and one of the things that really struck me as I dug into
these issues was that there's these immense,
complex challenges out there and it seemed,
and there's incredible people working on these issues who it's such dedication,
a lot of resources going into it,
but it just felt like we were barely making a dent.
Um,
and so I've been,
you know,
I think my journey over the last eight years has really been trying to figure
out not how I can make my own tiny little mark on some corner of some issue,
but really looking at the system and saying,
how can we do this better?
Um,
and trying to bring some of the experiences I've had at Google and other places
too,
some of these big social challenges.
And so I'm assuming people here generally have heard of the lean startup.
Is that yes.
Um,
and so I think the lean startup just is one of the books that's really captured
some of the best practices of innovation.
I think we live and breathe here at Google.
And you know,
Eric talks about the lean startup as a methodology for building products and
services under conditions of extreme uncertainty,
which is true for startup companies is true for a lot of things we're trying to
invent here at Google that have never been done before.
And I would argue it's equally if not more true when it comes to social
challenges cause we're talking about big,
complex,
longterm entrenched issues that we don't have solutions for.
Um,
and so in that case,
um,
there's a huge amount of uncertainty but yet what seems,
what I found to be true is that most of the organizations out there who are
trying to tackle these challenges are really good at predictable execution.
You know,
they like to create these grand master plans.
Maybe they don't like to do it,
but the system you know,
of,
of applying for grants and so forth forces them to create these grand masters
plans and they're expected to rigid,
execute rigidly to that plan.
Um,
sort of the opposite of what you,
we all know come innovation looks like.
So when there is such uncertainty,
I think what we need to do instead is look at approaches that help accelerate
the speed of learning.
And,
and this probably seems obvious to all of you and,
and I know lots of nonprofit leaders who have picked up the lean startup,
have heard about other innovation tools such as human centered design.
And they say this makes a lot of sense.
We want to do this.
And then they get stuck because they struggle with a number of barriers such as
the nature of how restrictive funding can be.
Um,
the difficulty of measuring impact,
um,
and the,
the length of time it can take to realize impact.
And also the whole notion of experimentation running ab tests sounds great.
When you're building a website,
it's a little harder when you're talking about experimenting on really
vulnerable people who are living on the edge.
And so that's really why I wrote this book is not to invent something new.
I'm not,
I don't come up with new methodology here that didn't exist before,
but to really look at how these best practices that have come out of places like
Google can be adapted for the realities of the context that organizations work
in who are trying to deliver social good.
Um,
until in the process of writing the book I spoke with,
I was lucky to interview over 200 organizations,
big and small domestic and international nonprofits and for profits,
funders and implementers,
and really try to see from among the most successful,
um,
what,
what were the core elements of their success.
And I kind of boiled it down into three principles.
And what was surprising to me is that the,
the traditional way of going about doing social good is exact opposite of this.
We tend to think too small,
start too big,
and get diverted by many things on the path,
the impact.
So let me start with think big.
So what I found is that most nonprofits,
the way that they go about their work is that they plan based on constraints.
You know,
we have this much money,
we have this,
this many people.
We have this grant opportunity that is this size and scope.
And so what can we do within this box we're in?
Um,
and they're usually do some good,
but it rarely moves the needle.
You know,
this is where it feels like we're doing so much work and working so hard and yet
we're never getting ahead.
Um,
I think the first shift that I,
that needs to happen is that we need to stop planning based on constraints and
start planning based on the need.
What is the actual need in the world?
What would actually move the needle on,
on changing,
addressing a real problem.
Um,
and,
and that's a really different approach.
You know,
here in silicon valley,
we know everybody's,
all the startup companies are running around with their PowerPoint decks that
show the hockey stick curve of how they're going to reach a billion people.
That doesn't happen in the,
in the social sector,
um,
very often at least.
Uh,
and it needs to,
because the are just as big.
Let me just kind of illustrate what that looks like.
Over the last 30 years,
we've made slow but steady progress on core social challenges like access to
clean water or electricity in sanitation.
And we say that,
you know,
we,
it,
this is really hard,
painstaking work because we're trying to reach people who are very poor,
who are living in very remote areas.
And so it's slow.
And yet during the same period of time,
adoption of mobile phones skyrocketed.
You know?
And,
and why,
what's the difference here?
One of the differences is that this is something people really want and demand.
So,
um,
I,
I've heard so many stories of people who will top up their mobile phone before
they'll buy food.
Uh,
and so today there's more people with mobile phones than have a toilet.
The other side is on the supply side.
The companies that manufacture or mobile phones make a profit and plow that into
making better phones for cheaper and distributing them.
The telecom companies that sell minutes are able to make a profit and so they
can build more towers,
reach more rural areas,
um,
deliver service more cheaply.
And so through this combination of strong demand and strong supply,
you see this kind of growth.
Um,
and certainly not everything in the social sector's going to look like this,
but I think we should challenge ourselves to say,
you know,
how do we shoot for something that it has this kind of trajectory.
And I think it's possible more cases than we think.
And that starts out by setting a goal setting higher sites.
I'm on a nonprofit here in the bay area called earn,
is focused on helping low income Americans develop a habit of savings.
And after 10 years in business,
they were being loaded at being the top of their field,
having 7,000 micro savings accounts.
And the founder of Bend Mangan one day woke up and he thought,
you know,
we're getting all this recognition,
but really there are an estimated 50 to 70 million Americans who could benefit
from this and we're reaching 7,000 after 10 years,
barely scratching the surface.
And so he got up at an awards dinner and made this grand announcement that they
were going to reach a million people in the next five years as a big stretch
from 7,000.
But what it did is it forced earned to relook at their model they were doing in
person visits to each of their clients.
They were doing a financial match.
And these things are short,
feasible if they're going to get to the scope of the need.
And so it forced them to take a different look at things and they ended up
building a technology platform that could reach a lot more people a lot more
cheaply.
And the first year after rolling out that platform,
they reached 85,000 people or more than 10 times as many as in their first 10
years combined.
So it's just an illustration of what it can look like to shift your mindset and
to shoot bigger.
And it often means that we don't necessarily know the path there yet,
but at least one,
if we're successful,
we can really move the needle.
So this is the second principle.
Lean impact is to start small.
Um,
you know,
we all know here that when we have,
great product idea that we want to start small,
we dog food things.
We've run AB tests,
we,
but,
but this is uncommon in the,
in,
in the social sector.
Um,
and we all know that by starting small we can make a bigger impact over time
because we can learn much more faster,
iterate much more quickly when we're experimenting with just five or 10 or a
hundred people versus trying to carry the infrastructure and all the logistics
related to serving thousands of people.
So the core of lean startup,
Eric talks about the build,
measure,
learn feedback loop,
right?
And the,
this is the cycle of iteration where we build an experiment.
We know we have a potential solution,
a hypothesis about what it will do.
We build an experiment and measure gathering the data and we learned and we
iterate through this.
So this is all very familiar to us in the tech world.
It's sort of familiar in the social sector.
The only problem is in the social sector,
this cycle usually takes years.
So in the global development space,
you know,
by that,
you're often designing a program for one or two or three years before it even
hits the field.
And then you run it,
say it's a five year program,
you run it for two and a half years,
you then do your midline evaluation,
which usually takes a year in it of itself.
Then you're three and a half injure your and you get some data and then you
might plow what you learned into your next proposal.
So the whole cycle could take like five or seven years to get through.
And so if you imagine these great complex challenges and you're only learning on
this cycle of like seven years,
you're not going to make a lot of progress.
And the world is only moving faster and faster.
So the key here is how do we speed up this feedback loop for social good so that
we can make faster progress and can take more risks and try more different
things,
can find much better solutions.
And so when it comes to social impact,
there's three dimensions that I think we need to test hypotheses around value,
impact and growth.
In the lean startup,
Eric talks about the value hypothesis and the growth hypothesis as a two core
hypothesis to test that we do within the,
um,
you know,
the tech industry certainly value hypothesis is certainly not only do people
want your product,
but they'll demand it,
come back for it,
tell their friends about it.
Growth is,
you know,
what is the engine for growth that's going to drive adoption?
You know,
are People gonna refer our folks?
Are they going to pay money for that?
You can plow back into investment and so forth.
But then for social impact,
we need to add a third hypothesis,
which is the impact hypothesis.
It's not enough to have something that people want and have it be able to get to
people.
Then you can just be talking about Nike shoes maybe.
But it also has to have social impact.
And too often we don't ask the simple question,
does it work?
Does it deliver the social benefit that we are seeking?
Um,
and so let me just talk briefly,
give a brief example for each of these three and what it might look like in the
social context.
So,
um,
for value,
you know,
this is testing.
Is this something that people will really demand and using engage with?
Um,
and an MVP for value will look very different in the salt can look very
different.
The social sector then when you're testing an online service,
in this case a social enterprise called copia global,
it's in Kenya.
They set out to look at how to provide a much wider range of consumer goods to
people living in rural areas that typically only have access to the basic
consumer staples.
And so rather than building out the infrastructure to transport goods to build
an online catalog or ordering system and warehouses and all this kind of stuff,
they decided to run an MVP.
Their MVP consisted of the CEO Crispin Er going to the local sort of Walmart
equivalent than Nakumatt and taking pictures of a bunch of different products
off the shelves of what he thought people might like.
And he pasted these into a handful of catalogs,
distributed into a few villages to and step back to see what would happen and as
questions,
where would people even want to order for a cat from a catalog?
What kinds of things would they order?
Would agents sell from the catalog?
And they learned a lot of things just from this process.
First they learned that people would order orders started coming in and when an
order would come in Crispin himself,
we'd go run to the store,
buy the product off the shelf and hand carry it to the village.
Now this is certainly not something that could scale,
but it's something that he could get up and running within a few days.
Um,
and so you validated the fact that yes,
people wanted these pro wanting to order from the catalog.
This was a value to people.
He also found out what kinds of products people wanted to order.
Um,
one of the surprises was that,
um,
today one of their most popular products is cement.
Not something they thought of initially.
But if you think about it going,
if you don't have a car going and getting cement and carry it home is actually
kind of hard.
And so it's something that people really value getting delivery of.
Um,
and then they had another surprise,
which is they originally thought that the agents that would be,
that they would use would be the people who are running these kind of kiosks,
the corner stores in these villages because they were already selling goods.
But it turned out that these,
these kiosk owners were more interested in moving the inventory they were
already carrying in their shops.
And so they didn't really try to encourage people to buy from the catalog.
And the people who ended up making much better agents were complimentary
businesses like hair salons where people will be waiting to get their haircut,
they could flip through the catalog and it would be an additional stream of
income.
So through this kind of MVP,
again,
that looks very different than if you're testing an online service.
They were able to learn a ton of stuff very quickly,
very cheaply,
that really helped them refine their service.
On the impact front.
One of the biggest challenges is,
as I mentioned earlier,
that it can take a long time to really fully realize impact.
One of the examples of where that's true is in education.
You know,
the educational attainment can take years to realize summit public schools is
another,
a nonprofit in the bay area.
And they set out with this idea of Diane Tavenner,
who's the founder out with the idea that she wanted to run to school for a
diverse student body are 100% of the students would graduate college.
Now they brought in all the best practices that they could find set up a charter
school and eight years later when their first cohort graduated from college,
what they found was they were doing significantly better than average and they
were getting all sorts of pressure to scale their model.
And Diane said,
wait,
slow down.
We're doing really good,
but we're still far short of the hundred percent,
um,
target we can do better.
But she also said,
there's no way.
I'm waiting another eight years to try something different and see if it works.
And so what she decided instead is to figure out how to build a culture and
process for speeding up learning within their organization.
And that consisted of coming up with a,
a platform where they could capture data.
So they,
they moved to a weekly cycle where they would do student assessments to see what
students learn.
They would have focus groups,
see what people were engaged with,
get feedback from teachers and so forth and gather all this data on a weekly
basis.
And they ended up running a 57 weeks of experiments,
kind of varying the length and duration in nature of different classroom
elements to come up with this revolutionary model of personalized learning.
Um,
and to,
and today that model of personalized learning has been adopted by over 300
public schools and they're,
the last year the,
um,
the,
their students had a 99% admission rate to college.
So they haven't graduated yet,
but they're learning much,
much faster now.
And so it was just an example that a lot of times,
even though the full impact may take a long time to realize there's earlier
indicators that we can capture that help us improve and refine our,
our interventions.
The third pillar of social innovation is growth.
Uh,
and I want to share the example of vision spring to,
to illustrate what growth might look like because it's very different than in
the private sector.
Uh,
so vision spring set out with their audacious goal was to take an innovation and
invention that's 700 years old that has been proven to increase productivity and
learning potential.
And that's eyeglasses.
We often think of innovation has got gotta be some whizzbang latest technology,
but they took something as 700 years old and yet two and a half billion people
who need eyeglasses don't have them today.
And so they set out to try to figure this out.
They started out by going to two geographies,
El Salvador in India,
US hiring some people,
they called vision entrepreneurs to do outreach to these two people in rural
areas and provide vision care.
And they came back with compelling stories of kids who are able to,
to learn of adults who are able to work again.
And for most nonprofits,
they would be thrilled by this.
They're making a huge difference in these people's lives.
But vision spring thought it wasn't enough.
They were losing money with every person they reached.
They would never be at a get to scale.
So they pivoted their second incarnation,
they created vision centers in more urban areas and uh,
served a more affluent population and took the profits from that to cross
subsidize outreach,
the more rural areas.
And so through this they become financially self sustainable again.
You know,
the holy grail for nonprofits,
I'm making a big difference and I'm financially self sustainable,
but it still wasn't enough because it would have taken them decades to be able
to scale their infrastructure to reach everyone they wanted to reach.
So they pivoted again.
They,
they ended up partnering with a organization and in Bangladesh called Brac that
has a network of community health work care workers in every corner of the
country and provided vision services through this existing network.
And so through this partnership,
they've now been able to reach over a million people on through additional
partnerships.
They've reached over four and a half million people.
And so now they're making a difference financially self sustainable and reaching
millions.
There's only one problem.
Four and a half million people is a tiny fraction of two and a half billion
people.
And they recognize that this is not something any one organization could solve.
There's a systems problem that manufacturers weren't incentivized to create low
cost enough classes and get them distributed to rural areas,
government or taking care of the basic vision needs of their populations.
And so they started a public private partnership called the alliance that brings
together eyeglass manufacturers and governments and nonprofits to look at these
systems issues.
And one of their first successes was um,
an MOU.
They signed with the government of Liberia,
who are the government agreed to integrate vision care into their public health
system and public school system.
And so you can imagine that as they look at this more at a systemic level and
try to influence policy and influence market dynamics,
that they have a hope of eventually getting to that two and a half billion
number.
So the last,
uh,
principle of,
of lean impact is to relentlessly seek impact.
Now this may seem like the obvious thing to do after all of these are mission
driven organizations.
Of course they're going to seek impact.
But it turns out that there's so many things that push in the opposite
direction.
Now you've all probably heard of this phrase,
Paul and love the problem,
not the solution.
And what I see with a lot of organizations is that people get excited about
applying a particular technology or the particular role of their organization or
they have pride of ownership over the design of an intervention that they've,
you know,
have invested their time and energy into and I've seen make a difference.
Um,
one of the indicators of this to me is I talked to lots of different
international NGOs who work in education or healthcare or agriculture and a lot
of them have similar programs and every one of them will tell me their program
is the best and they can't all possibly be.
Right.
Um,
and so we're not really being rigorous and looking at what,
what really is the best solution to a problem.
People are just,
you know,
getting accustomed to promoting their thing cause it's on their websites,
what they pitch to funders.
They're all,
everybody's saying why they're thing is the best.
And very few of them can tell me basic answer,
basic questions like what is the cost effectiveness of your solution so that we
can actually compare these things.
And so part of what I think we need to do is start looking at the right metrics.
Um,
w Eric talks about the vanity metrics as these absolute numbers of the number of
people we've reached or the number of dollars we've raised.
These are the things that organizations tend to highlight.
If you,
as much as they talk about mission on the outside,
on the inside,
if you go to the executive team meetings,
this is what they're talking about.
How many people do to reach,
how many dollars are we Rachel?
It's our grant pipeline.
None of these things have any correlation with impact.
You can reach a lot of people,
but did you actually improve their lives?
Um,
you can.
Uh,
and even if you did improve their lives,
could somebody else have done more with the same resources?
So instead,
what I think we need to focus on is the metrics on the right,
which are the,
what I call the innovation metrics.
These are the unit level metrics on value,
growth and impact.
Things such as the adoption rate,
the unit costs,
the success rate that will pay dividends over time as you optimize those.
Um,
and a lot of times we don't even know what the,
what the this data is.
When it comes to social interventions.
We're focusing too much on actually just reaching more and more people and not
on really optimizing for the basic unit drivers of success.
So I'll just wrap up by saying the ones,
if I could sum down,
one thing that I really wanted to accomplish with this book is to change the
mindset of the world for anybody,
any organization who cares about social good,
whether your debt,
you know,
volunteering your time,
you're donating your money,
you're working on a project for social good or otherwise.
I think we need to raise the bar.
You know,
companies are expected to maximize shareholder value,
maximize profits,
and we have all these regulations that forced them to do so and companies will
relentlessly maximize their profits.
I think we need to bring that same attitude to social good.
If you're a mission driven organization or you claim to be,
it's not enough to deliver some good weed.
We too easily let ourselves settle for delivering some good.
We made some difference.
Instead,
I think we need to hold ourselves accountable to maximizing the impact and scale
of our work.
And so to me that means setting those audacious goals,
really thinking about the size of the need,
but then starting small and testing and optimizing what we deliver around value
growth and impact and staying relentlessly focused on achieving the maximum
impact possible.
Thank you.
Um,
so I'm going to ask a few questions,
but get your questions ready.
We'll turn over in a minute.
So,
and May,
I think this is kind of a self selected group,
but I think you are a hero to many at Google because we tend to attract a
technologist and you won't care very,
very about
using their skills to change the world.
And so I think a lot of folks are asking themselves,
how can I make the most impact?
How,
you know,
uh,
on the issues I care about,
you know,
especially if I'm a technologist.
So what's,
what's your advice to all of these Googlers?
Yeah,
that was a question I was asking myself.
I,
I couldn't figure out,
okay,
I know how to build software.
How am I possibly going to make an impact on global poverty?
Um,
and this may be a little heretical given what google.org does,
but I think that the first thing people leave too is like,
let's figure out how to use technology.
And I think that using technology is absolutely a powerful tool that the social
sector generally does not know how to use well enough.
But I think equally if not more so it's how we build the technology.
I mean Google is not outstanding only because of the technology at bills,
but it's the process and system building,
right?
I often give the example of everyone thinks of Google is one of the most
innovative companies on the planet.
And yet if you look at it,
Google didn't invent search.
Like there was like infoseek and excited rate all those guys.
But,
but Google got better at search because it iterated and improved the user
interface,
that feature set the algorithms and so forth faster than anyone else.
And it's that sort of muscle of being able to do that that I think is really
missing from the social sector in addition to the technology.
So I think what I found is once I,
you know,
there's,
you have to start with a lot of humility because there's so much we don't know,
not living in that world,
but there's so much value we can add because,
um,
we bring a skill set that doesn't exist for the most part in the sector.
And so there's huge,
huge opportunity there.
Yeah.
Little infomercial for being a google.org,
uh,
fellow.
Uh,
we have some in the room here who have volunteered for some of our partners like
thorn and center for policing equity.
But you know,
our hypothesis is basically that we can help do the most good.
It's Google,
google.org and we're really leaning into providing resources,
but most importantly our Googlers.
And so we're sending out teams for six months at a time to really deeply,
deeply in bed.
And we've got some folks here who have done that.
But you know,
you raise a good point too in the book about,
um,
I think sometimes,
uh,
we can have some Hubris in the tech world and think that we sort of know
everything and it can just go in and solve everything.
And you know,
there's folks in the nonprofit world or just not that bright or not that
ambitious and you know,
I'm going to go in and teach them.
So what do you think is something that you've picked up from being on both sides
of the table that tech can learn from the nonprofit sector?
Well,
there's sort of the macro thing and then the micro thing on the,
on the macro level you had talked about the value growth and impact hypotheses
and,
and you know,
Eric started out with Silicon Valley being value and growth are the two
hypotheses.
I think that we're seeing pressure now around the world on the,
on the impact that tech has.
And I think that my hope is not only does the social sector adopt,
you know,
some of these tools from the tech sector,
but maybe some of this will flow back where we can also be looking at the impact
hypothesis is something we should equally weight and value as as we develop
products.
Because there's,
you know,
the kind of reach that Google and other companies have is huge.
Um,
and,
and we need to think about the impact we're having.
Um,
at a micro level,
I think that,
um,
one of the things I've seen is tech people coming into the social sector,
especially global development,
which is hard because you're working with people who are very,
very different than you,
who are very far away,
who have different cultures and languages and life's.
Um,
and I think there can be this Hubris to say,
hey,
we can build you an app for that.
Not to mention they don't have smartphones or let alone us signal.
Right.
Um,
and so people who have been in the social sector for in global development for a
long time,
I've worked in and out with the local populations and have a much better
understanding of the realities of what people live with.
And I think,
um,
we can often be naive and just zooming that if we build an APP or provide the
technology that it's going to change everything.
And there's so many,
you know,
that's like 2% of the problem and there's so many other dynamics at play we
talked to in the book and Brian Stevenson has this phrase get proximate.
You know,
how important it is for us to just roll up our sleeves and go and listen,
listen with empathy.
Um,
you know,
how has that played out in your career?
Yeah,
I think it's so essential to get proximate and not just like,
Eh,
I think sometimes people think get proximate means go take a trip to Kenya for a
week and talk to some people and come home and then you build your product.
Um,
one of the examples I give him the book is of proximity design incorporated that
into their name.
When they decided to work with small holder farmers in Myanmar,
they literally picked up and move there.
Cause what,
what allowed them to do is every day be living among and talking to the farmers
they were trying to serve and be able to design with them in,
in the whole process and every day,
be it as bringing prototypes and get their feedback.
And so they were able to speed up their feedback loop by being there and getting
that kind of feedback.
I think that's just so essential because we make so many bad assumptions,
especially when we're working with people who are so different than us.
It's like,
Eh,
you know,
I think innovating is so much,
one of the things I've learned is that innovating is so much harder in the
social sector for number of reasons.
But this is one of the reasons like here,
when we build products that Google,
we're generally building products that are for people like us and what I did
during my time at Google.
The problem.
Yeah.
During my time at Google,
I,
um,
the products that we failed that the most were the ones for people who are not
quite like us.
Um,
because we were so used to,
we have some,
we're not very diverse.
There's a lot of people aren't quite like us.
Yes,
exactly.
And I think,
yeah,
I think that's really an issue.
But when you're building products for people like you,
you can use the product,
you dog through the product,
you get generally pretty good feedback and you have a pretty good sense of how
people are going to respond.
That's completely different when you're working with vulnerable populations,
whether domestic or international that just don't have the same instincts,
assumptions,
culture that we do.
So one more question and then I'm going to open it up to the audience.
So,
um,
you know,
you're talking about,
uh,
the importance of nonprofits being able to be self sustaining.
And I think some of the problem in the nonprofit culture,
frankly,
are a lot of it is derived to just how a skewed they are by funders and that
funders of funder's acted more.
We sponsor Billy and inline with providing incentives around true impact.
You know,
I loved your slide about measuring true impact.
Um,
but do you have a thought on this,
uh,
you know,
social businesses versus nonprofits versus governments,
how do you think about the different roles that each of those kinds of groups
can play in this integrate question?
And,
and,
and funders is,
is probably the biggest barrier to innovation that,
that I consistently hear when I talked to nonprofits.
Um,
and just because of the nature of restricted funding,
I,
I think that both funders and nonprofits,
so donors and nonprofits are trying too much to solve the problem themselves.
And if you look at the,
just the numbers in terms of how much donor dollars there are and how much reach
nonprofits have,
they're not set up for almost any problem to be able to deliver at the scale
that's needed.
And so what I think we need to do is shift our thinking a bit and think of
donors in nonprofits more as incubators,
as the startups,
if you will,
to figure out the better solutions because they can be close to the problem.
They can experiment and take risks and figure out how to deliver better
services.
And when they do,
then I think the,
the,
there's like three general pads to scale that that are possible and depends on
the type of thing you're doing.
But one path,
this scale,
if you can develop a private sector business model,
but that may start with a nonprofit or social enterprise because the upside may
not be big enough and the risk may be too high for a private sector company to
take it on.
So that's what it is.
We're donors and nonprofits can sort of de risk and refine a model and then be
at a handed off to private sector to be able to take it forward.
Um,
the other end of the extreme is for basic social services.
Government is really the path to ScaleIO.
Government spends a lot of money,
you know,
many more times than philanthropy spins to providing social services towards
citizens.
Um,
you know,
whether it's education or healthcare or some of the biggest areas,
um,
but so where we can help government and more cost effectively spend his money by
coming up with new and better solutions,
we can leverage that money that government is already spending in a much better,
much better way to make a bigger difference.
And the third kind of path is some variation on,
on replication or franchising,
right?
That it's,
it can,
maybe it's not just one private sector company or one government,
but it can be lots of smaller organizations in different places who are all
adapting.
You know,
micro,
uh,
micro finance is sort of a great example of the replication model getting to
millions of people through both private sector and nonprofit models.
Great.
Well let's open it up to questions in the room and do we have any on the live
stream as well?
Yeah,
go ahead.
But I do have a question,
so,
and I apologize.
I was trying to figure out how to formulate this well.
Um,
I think there's a culture in Silicon Valley of scale is good,
right?
And like scales kind of thing that you want it.
I think I agree.
Like it'd be good to see more scale.
I think your quarterly or this though is that organizations that are trying to
scale then kind of ignore the problems that don't scale well and I think like
you kind of mentioned like the hockey stick graph of mobile phones sales going
up and like latrines not really.
And I think there's a reason why Google like cell phones and we don't sell the
trees and like I guess like my question is what do you think happens in like say
a decade when social impact organizations all started to say there becomes this
culture of like desire to scale and then kind of like a demand and like need and
like baseline is to scale.
And then they started to say,
okay,
we're going to ignore the hardest scale problems and only address the ones the
scale it like,
is that like,
is that something that you'd think there's a way to hedge against that or,
yeah,
it's a great question.
So I do think that I'm in just about every case.
We should be aiming for scale,
but I don't think that means we should pick off the easy problems.
I think that social sector organizations should focus on the toughest problems.
The reason we need a social sectors where both markets and governments are
failing.
Um,
and so it works in the government is already working like mobile phones.
You don't need nonprofits to get involved.
So they generally should be focused on the problems that aren't being taken up
by others.
And,
and I think for any kind of problem you should think about how to scale it.
I get a lot of questions from folks about how about like local community
organizations.
And one of the things I would say is that yes,
local community organizations are essential to be close to the community,
understand the community and so forth.
But I would ask a few questions.
First,
are you,
are you delivering the most cost effective intervention that you could,
you know,
whether it's you're trying to help the homeless or feed the hungry or whatever,
are you doing this as well as cost effectively as possible?
If not,
can you learn from or take practices from other organizations that are figuring
this out?
And if you are,
if you've gotten to the most cost effective way to do this and you're also
reaching all the people that need this,
you should absolutely tell other people how you're doing this.
So they don't have to all figure it out themselves.
And scaling doesn't mean having to scale your organization.
It means scaling the impact.
Um,
and so I think there's very few cases I can think of where you wouldn't want to
get the scale,
but that doesn't mean I don't see organizations say,
oh,
we're only going to tackle problems that get to scale.
I think they really have the problems they want to tackle.
The problem is that they're really focusing their success on delivering to a
finite number of people instead of looking at how to really get to everyone that
needs it.
And my question is about more tactically around when you think you already,
and I've seen before a context like 10 years ago I finished a masters in cs and
I got two offers.
One was non profit doing right to consulting and doing kind of capacity building
for nonprofits.
And the other one was for Google being a developer and I want you to go through
a nonprofit,
but they're my mentors.
Saa.
Good intentions are not enough.
Go get your Eq skills,
money,
network and stuff.
So then years have gone by and I'm still at reevaluating that and my question is
along the lines of when would,
when do you know you were ready to make a transition?
And I specifically looking back what their muscles are,
you fell you on their flex and muscle that you felt you over flexed.
Uh,
uh,
now that you are a on the other side,
yeah,
that's a great question.
It is a great question.
Um,
I made a somewhat arbitrary decision in my mid twenties.
I was going to spend half of my career in tech,
silicon valley and half my career.
So like for me it was just like,
oh,
now I'm like 42 or something like that.
It's time to do it.
Um,
I don't think there's one answer it,
I'll tell you my experience of this cause I think it's different.
Some people start from the beginning of the social sector and do great and other
people came come in very late.
For me,
what worked out well about doing it mid career is I think the reality is that
you can personally learn faster in the private sector.
Lynn's social sector,
there's a lot more resources,
there's a lot more talent and expertise.
Um,
there's a lot more competition.
Things move faster.
And so I felt like I developed skills at two or three times the rate I would
have by being in silicon valley than I would have if I just started in the
social sector.
Um,
and so the other thing is I think that because there's a lot of dysfunction in
the sector,
a lot of us I think would be pretty frustrated going into the social sector in a
junior level role where we're essentially executing on those grand master plans
at someone came up with.
And so for me it was more interesting going in where I could be in a senior
enough role that I had some say over the planning of things and the strategy for
things so that I felt like I could make a bigger difference and exactly what
point in time there.
I don't think there's an exact science to it,
but I think that spending enough time in the private sector to build up your
skills,
think about what you want,
your unique advantage to breathe when you go to the,
the organization,
uh,
to the,
to the social sector.
You know,
if it's,
you know,
tech technical capabilities,
again,
you'll learn faster here than you will there.
But then at some point you can bring it to government or to a nonprofit if it's
leadership experience,
that's a different type of thing.
That's an,
you know,
if it's an innovation experience,
those are the kinds of things that you can develop great expertise in at a place
like Google and then eventually be able to cross fertilize that to other types
of organizations.
I think the other thing that I tell folks,
cause I get asked this question a lot as well,
is,
um,
uh,
especially if you're right out of college,
I strongly encourage people to go get their transferrable skill in business.
You know,
whether that's accounting or marketing our coding,
you know,
get really do what Ann Mei was saying,
but be careful that you don't,
uh,
create a lifestyle that's unsustainable to work in government or nonprofits
because those same people who I counsel sometimes I check in five years later
and they're like,
ah,
man,
I got this mortgage and yeah,
I wanted to do,
you know,
go work for give directly,
but I can't.
And you know,
so,
uh,
there's some practicalities to it too in terms of making,
freeing yourself to do the kinds of things that you want to do at a certain
season.
Yeah.
That,
that's a great point.
And the other way to do it is not necessarily to have it be a one way shift.
Right?
That,
that I think this fellowship that you've talked about,
which is sounds new,
I cheated.
Oh,
would you do if something that didn't exist when I was at Google,
I made up my own fellowship,
essentially took a leave of absence.
Um,
but,
but you know,
the u s government now has the US digital services and 18 f where they're taking
people in for like one or two years and then you can go back to your job.
And so it doesn't,
for some people it doesn't necessarily make sense for it to be a one way street.
You may want to come back,
but you could take a year or two out and do something to contribute back.
Any idea of where to fundraise when nonprofit needs to be agile,
try fail,
iterate without showing appealing concrete impact numbers to donor.
Yes.
That is hard because most big donors tend to like to fun very,
uh,
rigid defined programs.
Uh,
the good news is that,
and they liked the big reach numbers.
Yes,
they do.
Speaking for a friend.
Um,
so I,
it's hard to answer this in a general sense.
The good news is I think more and more donors are waking up to this.
I spent a lot of time going around talking to donors and both,
there's a lot of more innovative,
smaller donors like google.org,
um,
uh,
echoing green draper Richards Kaplan give well.
So there's a lot of these kind of smaller,
more innovative donors,
if you will,
uh,
that specialize in,
in kind of Mulago Foundation here that specialize in kind of helping,
allowing people to iterate and fail and experiment and so forth.
And so finding the relevant ones in your space is great.
The other good news is that more and more,
the big donors are also starting to do this and not necessarily in the core of
what they're doing,
but the,
almost every donor now has something on the side where they have more flexible
funding.
So at USA id we had the development innovation ventures that was modeled after
venture capital that did tiered funding that started at $100,000 at $1 million
and $5 million.
We could take a lot more risk.
Um,
and then we spun out the Global Innovation Fund that similar we have the grand
challenges that are similar on specific,
um,
uh,
issues that,
that we're where we need better solutions.
So there's a lot of different things out there.
Whoever asked this question,
I'm happy to talk to depending on your specific types of,
and a lot of work who asked the question.
It's done a lot of work internally on Google social impact projects.
Yeah.
And,
and I would encourage you all that as you donate money also those donors
yourself,
even if you're not,
you know,
a huge mega donor like the gates foundation,
um,
you can help organizations by giving them unrestricted money to allow them to do
this kind of experiment.
And there's,
if you don't have the time or sort of know how to do the research to find those,
you can use proxies like give well and our groups like fast forward who are
funding tech based nonprofits who you can,
you know,
sort of use them as a proxy for really understanding deeply,
uh,
the impact.
Uh,
if you could talk a little bit about how,
like you would make the pitch for this type of approach in industries.
Where are the government,
for example,
where things tend to move a lot slower?
Because I can imagine if you were to take this approach,
like you give a couple examples of like how spots and the federal government are
becoming more innovative with their spending,
but they tend to be very niche programs.
Whereas I can imagine if you took this to like a career program officer,
they might perceive,
oh,
someone from Silicon Valley's and an outsider.
So how do you,
how do you make a pitch for like rapid iteration and a place where the culture
is kind of like what we've always done it this way?
Yeah,
it's a great question.
I mean,
government is a huge institution and it changes very slowly.
The good news is that there are career people.
So,
so this was essentially my charter at USA id.
I,
I was the first executive director for the global development lab.
We're set up as a bureau to really promote,
you know,
transform global development.
And,
um,
you know,
we're a little corner of the agency,
but our,
our mission was to go reach out to other parts of the agency,
find those advocates,
work with them to build success stories.
So it's a,
it's,
it's just like adoption of any new thing.
Um,
you have to go step by step.
And so we would start by experimenting ourselves,
showing it could be done,
then we would partner with the early adopters across the agency that we could
find the senior foreign service officers who were like mission directors but who
are forward leaning.
And we'd get a handful of them to try stuff with us and show that they could do
it.
And they had their own network of other senior foreign service officers that
trusted them that they could then tell and be then be our advocates and spread
the word further.
And so it's,
you know,
it's step by step,
that kind of adoption curve that takes a long time.
And one of the most exciting things for me in writing this book is,
you know,
I,
I left USA ID and government at the end of the Obama Administration when I
launched this book three months ago at the Brookings Institute in DC.
One of the speakers on the panel,
like Jacqueline is being here,
um,
was Jim Richardson who's one of the most senior political appointees in USA ID
as part of the Trump administration.
He runs the policy and Budget Bureau for USA id and he read the whole book.
He said,
this is exactly what we're trying to do.
We're trying to move all our procurement so that 30% of what we're spending is
going through innovative funding mechanisms.
And so even this administration,
which you know,
has its challenges is still moving these things forward.
Um,
and so I do think there's movement but it will be slow because government is
just slow.
We've found too and working with as google.org and worth working with USA ID for
example,
we've been supporting using direct unconditional cash transfers as a benchmark
as you talk about household grants.
Yeah.
And,
um,
worked with USA ID to uh,
do some ab testing with them.
And I think sometimes as you were saying,
other groups can help de-risk ideas,
prove them out.
But really the government groups like USA idea,
the ones who are going to do things at scale.
So us doing a partnership with USA id,
you know,
it was way to take an idea,
test it out,
see,
see where it works,
where it doesn't and have government bring it to scale.
Yeah,
you're always gonna have people who are going to drag their feet.
But I think you all also are always going to have people who really are mission
driven.
If they see something's going to work better and get better results and save
lives.
And our case,
it was like the Rwandan mission set forward and it was like,
we want to do this.
You know?
So it's,
it's finding folks within.
And when you went to,
we've talked a lot about government,
but when you went into the nonprofit sector as well,
you went into an innovation was at the innovation lab at mercy wasn't called an
innovation.
I lead the social ventures team.
Yeah.
Social ventures.
And so even with our large,
you know,
uh,
multinational and nonprofits as well.
Similarly,
there are ways to,
yeah.
And I think almost every of the large international NGOs now,
almost every one of them has some sort of innovation lab now.
Yeah.
Um,
I know that government often has a strain on it spreadsheet,
whether that's like San Francisco City Hall or maybe USAID.
Um,
so I'm really interested in public private partnerships.
Uh,
in your research,
did you see any good example of a government working with companies to scale
their impact?
Um,
government working with comp you mean?
Yeah,
like for example,
I know in San Francisco maybe the local government will work with nonprofit.
We'll work with companies in the area to provide jobs for people,
you know,
like have an impact that the government might not have budget for.
[inaudible].
I see,
I see.
Yeah.
Um,
so it is true that government is always crunched by budgets,
but I think it's also true that we don't spend government money very effectively
a lot of the time.
So,
um,
so I think that's what private sector can really help.
Um,
I'm not sure the kind of projects you're,
you're thinking about.
There's such a range of public private partnerships,
which is why I was asking that.
We worked on at USA ID.
I was responsible for our partnerships office as well.
And so,
uh,
you know,
one of the categories is what people call shared value.
So classic is,
you know,
Starbucks working or Walmart working to source from smallholder farmers are from
disadvantaged populations to try to create economic growth for those folks.
But while getting the goods that they need for their own supply chains,
so that's where we will cross subsidize a sensual,
where grant money can go into to do the technical assistance to go find all the
farmers,
build collectives and so forth and connect them to the supply chains that then
companies can kind of take over and be able to operate on a ongoing basis.
We also did things,
um,
at the lab for example,
we would fund for profit entities as well as nonprofit entities in the early
stages to do risk.
They're new,
they're new innovation.
So we did a lot with the off grid energy sector where,
um,
we're,
you know,
the sort of pay as you go solar where we put in some of the earliest money to
experiment with these pays you go solar systems.
Um,
and then over time,
uh,
as the systems were proven,
as they became financially self sustainable impact,
investors started coming in to be able to fund them and at much much greater
degree to then we would have been able to.
And so there's lots of different ways and that,
that,
and,
and I think a lot of these kinds of public private partnerships like the Ilyas I
talked about earlier where,
um,
where private sector and governments come together for collective action.
I started something that Google was involved with called the Alliance for
affordable Internet that was looking at how do we expand access to internet
around the world by addressing market failures and Po policy failures.
Um,
so just a few examples but the,
but very important.
So we have like four minutes left.
So I wonder if we could try to hit the,
are remaining questions quickly.
So one of the argument about implied schools are so static is that it's hard to
test iterate on other people's Children's.
What ways are ways innovative young,
radical ideas can be validated without risking wellbeing of other folks?
Um,
it was a great question.
So I think that a couple of answers to that.
One is on the summit public schools thing.
This was like an optin kit.
People knew that their kids were going,
it wasn't like we're going to experiment with your children or not tell you is
that they saw enough value in what was being provided there and they felt like
they were still going to get a better education than they would otherwise that
people opted into this.
Um,
and I think that's important that people need to make,
have conformed consent.
And that can be a little trickier when you're working with vulnerable
populations.
I think two things I would say to this one is that it's one of the reasons that
we need to start small.
So when you experiment with very only a very small number of people,
you can pay much more attention to making sure that they are made whole and that
nothing bad happens or not unintended consequences because you can watch what
happens with five people much more easily than thousands of people.
The other is I think that,
so we need a tear up those risks and not take too big a recipe for we're ready.
The other is,
um,
I think we also need to ask the question of what is the risk of not doing
anything.
So we think of vaccines,
for example,
if no one was ever given the first polio vaccine,
there is a risk to that person's life who got the first polio vaccine.
There was millions of people would have died otherwise,
but you don't irresponsibly just randomly give someone a polio vaccine.
You test in a petri dish that you test it with Rasta and texted with monkeys.
And then when you get to testing it with people,
you watch very closely,
but you still take some risks.
But it's that measured risk.
And you look at the upside of the first successful,
the number of people so she can save.
Hi.
Um,
one of the sections in your book that really stuck out to me was when you talked
about the different type of like impact numbers that result from both like an
ecommerce business.
You talk more about the 30 day active,
you know,
you could do like,
like sign up,
completes,
et Cetera,
more silicon valley numbers that were used to,
um,
but then how the impact numbers for social impact takes years to see that same
type of result.
Um,
so I was wondering,
have you had any recommendations of a set of numbers,
maybe three categories of numbers that can sit in the middle?
So not quite 30 day user active,
but not quite like a four year RCT that can help both funders and nonprofits
guide and tell the story of whether or not a program is successful.
Yeah,
I can't give you generic,
um,
metrics because they're going to be different depending on the type of
intervention.
Uh,
what I would say is that I look at almost every nonprofit has like a theory of
change for what,
you know,
we're going to train these farmers,
then they're going to have better farming techniques,
then they're going to have better yields for the crops in and you're gonna have
higher incomes and you know,
whatever that you have a theory of change.
And part of testing for impact is testing those linkages and the theory of
change.
We tend to create these elaborate theories of change and then put them on the
bookshelf and then just run through the whole program and then try and do an RCT
at the end.
But if you've tests each of those linkages,
it's like if you train the farmers,
did they actually do what you trained them to do?
If they didn't,
you don't have to wait four years to figure out if their incomes increased.
So what are those simpler earlier indicators that tell you?
And so you'll summit public schools did this by measuring learning assessment
each week to say,
hey,
we tried this thing that the students learn better than doing it some other way.
Um,
and so it really depends on the nature of their intervention.
All right,
last question.
Yeah.
Uh,
so my sense is that a lot of small organizations in particular hat,
you know,
their thought processes kind of,
well sure it would be great to quantify things and know how we're doing,
but we're just spending all of our energy and effort doing kind of the real work
of the organization,
you know,
helping her target population,
whatever it is.
So like,
how do you pitch to those groups that reorienting some of their efforts toward
coming up with metrics,
quantifying things,
tracking those metrics is worth the effort.
Yeah,
that's a great question.
Um,
one is that I think funders need change funder behavior number one,
capital.
Cause like when your funders are telling you to give us numbers,
it's really hard to do something different.
I'll give us real numbers.
Yeah.
Outcomes.
And also I think that I,
you know,
in the book I talk about starting with a,
an audacious goal.
So too often it's a short term,
longterm tradeoff,
right?
You can deliver more in the short term by just cranking out stuff.
But you're never going to bend the curve to accelerate your growth in the
longterm.
So you end up like the clean water or sanitation graph.
Um,
and so it,
it,
it means,
you know,
setting that audacious goal because when most nonprofits have goals that they
can meet just by working a little bit harder.
And so if you have a goal that's like 10% better than last year,
there's no reason to take risks.
There's no reason to innovate.
There's no reason to potentially fail.
But if you have a goal that's longer term,
that's like,
we got to get to 10 x or a hundred extra thousand x,
then you know,
as you're doing your thing,
you can sort of see,
are you on your trajectory to get there?
You know?
And,
and so I asked nonprofits like,
what's your definition of success?
What does success look like in 10 years or 20 years?
Could push it out far enough that they're not trying to project what they're
doing today,
but then look at are we on a trajectory to get there?
And if not,
and this is your mission,
what do we need to do to try to shift the curve so that we,
we changed the trajectory,
but let's give a warm thank you to the hero of many of us who is helping to not
only create,
you know,
a product or do one small thing for one small group,
but really help an entire sector of government and the social sector to
understand how to be innovative and how to really create systems change.
Thanks again,
man.
Thank you so much.